[APPLAUSE]
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
I'm Siobhan Roberts.
And I am John Horton
Conway's biographer.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: And
I'm that person mentioned.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
John Horton Conway.
The book is just out.
It was published on July 14.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
Bastille Day.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Yes, indeed.
Nodal.
There's a few
copies at the back.
And we'll be happy to
sign them afterwards.
And I also should say, feel free
to interrupt us at any point
if you have a
question pertaining
to what we're talking about.
There's mics in the aisles.
But I thought we could start
by doing a brief reading
from the book as is sort of
traditional on these occasions
because I thought
that would give you
a sampling of the book.
And at once give you
a sense of the process
that poor John endured
throughout the course
of my writing the
book and the process
that I endured in
writing about poor John.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
Let me just interrupt
to say I'm a bit
testy already today.
So that might very
well-- I'm supposed
to read these yellow lines
on this piece of paper.
You don't know which the yellow
lines are, but never mind.
I do.
I can see them.
I'm also a little bit
upset, I must say-- well,
more than a little bit-- at the
paranoia of Google demanding
that we produce identification.
Had I known that I was
to produce identification
before being let in, I would
not have accepted the invitation
to talk today.
I'm really serious.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: All right.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: OK.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
Thank you for that.
So this is from the chapter on
the Game of Life in the book.
I thought we'd throw
caution to the wind.
So I'll just read a bit of an
intro to give you some context.
"So all hell broke loose
with the Game of Life
when Martin Gardner, the
'Scientific American'
columnist, wrote his October
1970 column about life.
In the column--"
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
Capital life.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
Capital life, yes.
"In the column, Conway
issued a challenge-- $50
for the first person
to find the piece
of circuitry in the computer--
the glider gun-- that would
all but prove life universal.
And the pandemonium has
continued ever since.
On a local level, these days
talking about life with Conway
can cause considerable
perturbation.
Without much warning, he reaches
his threshold and turns testy.
It terrifies--"
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: When he
already is, it gets worse.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
"It terrifies him
that his worst nightmare
might come true,
this his life will-- in the
end-- be reduced to life.
When we met for a session in
the alcove at the Princeton math
department one day,
he tried to prepare me
for the hellish consequences,
i.e., the wobbly
that he was about to throw.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: I don't know
what a wobbly is, but anyway.
It says here, "oh god, I
don't know whether to tell you
now or not."
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: "Oh
sure, get it over with."
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: "Well,
it may be upsetting to you.
It's upsetting to me actually.
I lay in bed probably
about a week ago,
in the early hours
of the morning,
and I've decided, I
have to say, that I'm
becoming fairly disenchanted
with your biography.
It's basically because
recently you've
been asking me these
questions about the Life Game.
And you know something?
I hate the Life Game.
I've really realized I hate
the-- what's that word?--
damned Life Game.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: "Well,
that can go in the book."
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
"Yeah, let me finish.
So I'm scared of the
following thing happened.
I'm scared of becoming
another one of these,
John Conway, inventor of the
celebrated Game of Life."
How many people know about
the celebrated Game of Life?
I can't see.
Oh, they all do, don't they?
[LAUGHTER]
"As I told you, every
time I turn to a book--
a new math book-- I look
up a certain sacred name.
And it says, Conway, Game
of Life, pages 34 to 38.
And that's roughly all it says.
And it's quality assassination,
not character assassination.
I did discover it.
And it was part
of my little life
to have discovered it and so on.
And I don't think it
should be totally excised,
but it seems to be all
that I'm known for.
And I wanted you to
somehow set the record
straight by not doing the
same damn thing again.
I mean, god, I was quite upset.
I was so terrified
that I was thinking
of saying, so to speak,
publish and be damned.
I don't want anything
more to do with it."
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: "May I speak?"
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
"Permission to speak?
No, not yet.
You should appreciate something.
This was never a big deal
as far as we were concerned.
We met a bunch of
graduate students
at Cambridge [INAUDIBLE].
This was just a recreation,
a game we played.
Somehow it became a bit more
important later on, or at least
it did in the eyes
of other people.
I never thought of
it as very important.
I still don't, by the way.
I just thought of
it as a bit of fun.
In a way, I felt ashamed of it.
I don't think it counts in
the mathematical community,
at least in the serious
mathematical community.
I don't think any of
my Princeton colleagues
thinks it's of any importance.
I don't know.
In a way, it doesn't
count for me.
So I wasn't going to cooperate
anymore in this character
assassination.
I wasn't going to answer
any more of your questions
about Life.
Well, I don't mind answering
a few to tell you the truth.
Just let me say--
how can I say it?
It was a genuine
part of my life.
And I told you about my
[INAUDIBLE] time and so on,
but I really want you to
minimize it rather than
maximize it.
OK.
Now speak."
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: "Ha.
Well, the less said, the better.
That seemed the best
means of assuagement.
It's a fool's errand attempting
to reason with John when
he's in a state."
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: And I'm
in a state now, by the way.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
So that gives you
just a sampling from the book.
But now maybe to sort
of backtrack a bit
and give you some
broader context--
this process started
initially when
I was writing my first
book about Donald Coxeter.
And everybody told
me I had to talk
to John Conway about Coxeter.
Yes.
And so it took me
awhile to track him down
because I don't think you were
really using email much then
and you weren't reliably
answering the phone.
So I was going about my research
and everything was turning up
geometry.
And then finally I
discovered that Conway
was going to be at math camp.
I think it was in
Maine that year.
And so I sought you
out at math camp.
I don't know if
you remember that.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
I don't remember
any particular incident.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Right.
So this is Donald Coxeter.
My first book was "King
of Infinite Space-- the
Man who Saved Geometry."
Coxeter was a very sort of prim
and proper Edwardian gentleman.
And as I said--
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Have we
got a picture of him here?
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Yeah.
He was up on the screen there.
He was known as the
Man who Saved Geometry.
And then so I
sought Conway out--
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: He was
one of my heroes, by the way.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Right.
Yeah.
And I sought you
out at math camp.
And in contrast to Coxeter, this
is what I found essentially.
You blended in so
well with the campers,
looking exquisitely filthy.
And you hadn't
slept in a few days.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: I should
tell you about math camp a bit.
Math camp was one
of two math camps.
It's one for 16-, [? 17-, ?]
18-year-olds good at math,
nerds, and so on.
And it wanders around the
United States and Canada.
And I used to devote one week to
it every year and another week
to MathPath, which is for
13-, 14-, 15-year-olds--
or maybe 12-, 13-,
14-year-olds-- fooling around.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Mm-hm.
And that's what you were
doing when I found you.
For sure.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yeah.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
But it was great,
because I got you
in your milieu.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
It's so great
that I'm not programmed anymore.
I don't have to read the yellow
lines on this piece of paper.
Sorry.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Right.
And so when I was trying to
interview you about Coxeter,
similarly I had an idea of
what I needed to accomplish.
But you did tell me how much you
loved Coxeter and admired him
and how you consider
yourself an honorary student.
But you also told me
rather a lot about yourself
at that time and place.
And so I thought, a-ha,
here is another book,
because you're such a
fabulous storyteller
and you do like to
talk about yourself.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
You mean liar?
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: No, not always.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: You
caught me out in one big lie.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Ah.
Well, I could read that
section from the book.
Or maybe you should tell
the story about Cromwell.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: No, not yet.
No.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Not yet.
Save that for later.
Well, do you want to say a
few things about Coxeter?
You wrote him a letter.
This is the letter.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Oh, yes.
I wrote him a
letter when I was--
I thought it was when
I was in high school,
but it was apparently when I
was at university-- Cambridge
University-- possibly
in my first year.
I don't exactly know.
Coxeter was a wonderful
man, a geometer,
living in Toronto, which is
how Siobhan got to know him.
But he edited Rouse Ball's
"Mathematical Recreations,"
which I read eagerly at school--
at high school, that is to say,
in Liverpool-- and then wrote
to him with various things.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: A
rather long letter.
It's a five-page letter.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
Five-page letter.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Yes.
Rather verbose.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
Illegible to me now.
But, still.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Mm-hm.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Then I
gradually got to know him.
He's one of a number of
people that I got to know
and knew in the end
for about 50 years.
And, you know, then people
who you know for 50 years
tend to die in their late 90s.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
He was 96, yeah.
Mm-hm.
And so I had met
Coxeter when he was 93.
And I knew him for three years
while I was writing the book.
And then the book
came out in 2006.
And then I--
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: That is
her biography of Coxeter.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Yes.
Mm-hm.
And then I went to the Institute
for Advanced Study for a stint
as a Director's Visitor.
And I had previously proposed to
John the idea of the biography,
but you said no, never.
Why did you say no initially?
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Well, I was
married to a certain lady who
I thought would be infuriated by
anything I said about anything.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
Well, by then you
were divorced from
that certain lady
and married to another lady.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yes.
But still--
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: It all
factors in together.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: --it
doesn't stop certain ladies
from-- never mind.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Right.
OK.
But then you changed your mind.
So when I arrived
at Princeton, I
called you up just to say hello.
And you said, hey,
about that biography.
So how did you change your mind?
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Well, there
was a rather strange person--
Matthew [? First-- ?]
at Princeton
who was some kind of
administrative assistant.
And I told him some
story-- I forget
which one it was because I have
a number of stories that just
get embellished over
the years until they
become totally false.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
They're all in the book.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
Oh, I don't know.
Fortunately a few
of them aren't.
But anyway, and
Matthew said, oh,
somebody should really
write your life story.
And I said, well, there's this
young woman who was going to,
but I said no.
And he said, well,
why did you say no?
And I said, well--
well, I told him
about the certain lady who
would be infuriated by anything
that was said, so to speak.
And he said, oh, well, look,
you can talk to your biographer
and arrange to keep
clear of anything
that might really upset her.
Anyway, after some
considerable talk--
more or less an
afternoon of talk--
he persuaded me to say yes.
Now Siobhan was-- this
conversation I remember-- maybe
falsely-- took place in
January of a certain year.
And Siobhan was going to
come to Princeton in February
of that year and was
phoning every now and then
to make arrangements
or something.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: I might
say it was September,
but, I mean, who's
going to quibble?
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Probably.
I said, as I remember, so
that means-- it means nothing.
So when she did
turn up, I-- well, I
had decided to look
at her face somehow.
And when I said I
might be prepared
to say yes or
something, I was going
to [INAUDIBLE] to seeing
something about her face.
And I discovered
later I've never
really looked at her face.
But anyway--
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: You were too
distracted defending yourself.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Passed over.
So, yes, I said, in the end.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Right.
And then something
interesting developed, for me,
in the process of talking
to you so many times.
I was at the Institute
on a number of occasions,
numerous visits over the course
of maybe four or five years.
And I would go over
to the department
and interview John on
any number of subjects,
such as FRACTRAN, which was a
precursor to the Game of Life.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: No.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Well, OK,
but just let me continue.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: It wasn't.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: You
can correct that.
But interviewing
you so frequently
and listening to
your stories again
and your fabulous way of
explaining things in such a way
that even I could grasp
the gist of things
or intuit an understanding-- I
realized that it would really
be a disservice if
I were to approach
the book in a traditional
way and translate my subject,
try and set it up
with a third person
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Did you
say it would or wouldn't?
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: It
would be a disservice.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Disservice.
OK.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Yeah.
So instead I just
decided I needed
to capture Conway and distill
him and let him really
come through on the page.
And so what I ended
up doing was allowing
you to speak in the biography
in extended quotations.
And I also convinced
my publisher
to give you your own font,
which was no small task,
I may say, because it made
the production and layout
of the book more difficult.
So John has his own font in
the book, comes in and out.
We pass the narrative
baton back and forth.
And I leave it to you
to explain things,
like the surreal numbers
and the free will theorem
and all the various
mathy gems and nerdish
delights that you're
so passionate about.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yeah.
I don't know what I
can say right now.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Well,
maybe you could tell us
a bit about the surreal numbers
or the free will theorem.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yes.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
The surreals are
the thing you're most proud of.
I mean, the Game of Life,
we can write that off.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: I'll
just tell you roughly
what the surreal numbers are.
I suppose, more or
less, everyone here
knows what the real numbers are.
So that's part of
the surreal numbers.
The word surreal
wasn't chosen by me.
It was chosen by
Donald Knuth, who
wrote a little book called
"The Surreal Numbers"--
or called "Surreal
Numbers" actually.
They form an enormous field of
numbers-- absolutely enormous--
that contains the real
field and lies above it.
Hence the term surreal.
But the term surreal also
carries the notion of bizarre
with it.
And they are a
little bit bizarre.
Well, quite a lot bizarre.
They also include Cantor's
infinite ordinal numbers,
which are not very
familiar to people.
So I suppose you know
nothing about them.
Cantor did a wonderful thing
in the decade-- Georg Cantor,
famous German mathematician--
did a wonderful thing
in the decade from 1870 to 1880.
He founded the theory
of transfinite numbers,
or just infinite, if you
like-- past the finites.
Everybody else stopped counting
somewhere at the finite stage.
Cantor actually copied
the usual way of counting,
starting at one.
But it's nicer to
count starting at zero.
So I'll start at zero.
It doesn't make very
much difference.
Zero, one, two, dot, dot, dot.
Everybody stopped,
say, at 2,417,
or some other finite number.
Cantor carried on,
imagining counting
an infinite collection,
getting to the end,
and then you have
a problem of what
the next number is after all
the finite whole numbers.
And Cantor originally
called it infinity,
but it doesn't behave
like the infinity
that people know from calculus.
So after a time he
rubbed a little bit
of the infinity symbol off and
took the Greek little omega
as his notion for the first
infinite number counting
number, omega.
And then there's omega
plus 1, omega plus 2.
You see, you can't
afford to go on inventing
different names all the time.
You know, there are an awful
lot of finite numbers even.
And so there's the
number we-- well,
in England we call
"a hundred and one."
In America, you call
"a hundred one."
Really "a hundred and one"
is a little bit nicer, or 100
plus 1, 100 plus 2, and so on.
We haven't invented separate
names for all of those.
Once we got 100, 101
is the next number.
So with Cantor, omega
plus 1, omega plus 2,
dot, dot, dot, omega
plus n typically,
and then omega plus omega,
which is omega times 2.
Omega times 2 plus 1,
omega [SOUND EFFECT].
It goes on and on and on
and on and on and on and on.
They're wonderful things,
Cantor's ordinal numbers.
It means counting numbers.
And then I found
some other numbers.
In fact, I found more numbers
than anybody else-- far
more numbers than anybody else.
In particular, there's
an infinitesimal number--
1 over omega and so on and
omega plus pi and omega minus 1
and all sorts of other things.
So it gets a bit surreal.
It's so horrendously
large, this world
of numbers, that I went around
in a daydream for about six
weeks-- permanent daydream.
I could see these numbers
spread out in front of me,
or at least I tried to see them.
And if was a huge world--
really huge-- of numbers.
And I must admit that I thought,
hm, you discovered it, John.
Nobody else had ever seen it.
I'm John, by the way.
And there's a thing
about [? stat courses ?]
crossing the American continent
and seeing the Pacific finally.
He was [INAUDIBLE].
Of all he surveyed.
Well, I was [INAUDIBLE]
of all he surveyed too--
of all I surveyed,
perhaps I should say.
I wondered whether Cantor
had had similar feelings.
Cantor eventually-- well, he was
institutionalized several times
and died in a lunatic asylum
in Halle, which later became
part of East Germany in 1918.
A wonderful man.
Yeah.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: And
you said that you're
disappointed that the surreals
haven't found a broader
application so far.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: I am.
You see, Cantor's
infinite numbers
have found applications really
just within mathematics,
but still applications.
It's only in
mathematics that you
want to count infinite sets.
So I feel that the
surreal numbers
are so natural that they will
find an application someday.
The truth is I'm
probably going to be dead
when they find an application.
And I don't really like that.
I was very pleased
to see that you
quote Peter Sarnak in the book
as saying the surreal numbers
will be applied someday.
It's just a question of when.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
When and how, yeah.
Now you had an encounter,
shall we say, with Kurt Godel.
You had read
something that he said
that gave you hope that they
might crack open the continuum
hypothesis.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Godel
was the famous mathematical
logician-- in fact, the
mathematical logician
since Aristotle.
Possibly one has to go
all the way back there.
But anyway, he found
a tremendous amount
about mathematical logic.
And in 1940 something-- I
always thought it was 1944,
but I think it's 1947-- he
wrote a paper called "What is
the Continuum Problem?".
The continuum
problem was the first
of the problems--
what were they called?
The Hilbert problems set
forth at the beginning
of the 20th century for
mathematicians to work on.
It was sort of solved
in a sense in that it's
known that it doesn't follow
from the other axioms of set
theory and nor
does its negative.
But that's not really
saying it was solved.
It was unsolved in a way.
But Cantor said in this
paper in the 1940s--
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Godel.
Godel said, yeah.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Sorry.
Godel said that
perhaps we would only
know the solution of
the continuum problem
when we had the correct
theory of infinitesimals.
And I thought I had the correct
So when I met Godel-- and
I can't quite remember--
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: In the '70s.
Early 1970s, yeah.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yeah.
Well, I was overawed by meeting
the man, to tell you the truth.
But I was keen to say I seem
to have the correct theory
of infinitesimals.
Now tell me how that affects
the continuum problem.
And he said, did
I really say that?
Oh well, I was wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, it's not kind to laugh
so uproariously because it
sort of shattered me in a way.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Yeah.
But I think there's still hope.
I mean, there's been
people who've tried.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: I mean,
yeah, I think he was wrong,
too, actually.
I mean, I couldn't see any
effect of it on the thing.
That's why I really asked him.
I mean, I couldn't
see any relation.
And neither could he when he saw
what the surreals were about.
I think he agreed that they
were the correct theory
of infinitesimals.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Now
the other contribution
that you're very proud
of is your free will
theorem with Simon Kochen.
Do you want to tell
us a bit about that?
And then we can
take some questions.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: That's
a very strange theorem.
It says subject to certain
facts about physics that are not
contentious among
physicists that if we have
free will-- that is to
say human experimenters
have a little bit of free will.
They don't have
to have very much.
That so do elementary
particles have
the same amount of free will.
It's not so terribly
clear what free will is.
But I'm just going to say I
don't believe my action there
in picking up this
whatever it is
and dropping it on the
floor was determined
by the positions of the
particles and momentum
and so on of particles at
the time of the Big Bang.
I think that's really
rather ridiculous.
And that's what strict
determinism says.
And in Newtonian
mechanics that was true.
[INAUDIBLE] the greatest
expert on Newtonian mechanics
said in several different
places that if an Intelligence--
this Intelligence was spelt
with a capital I-- knew
the positions of all
positions on momentum
and so on, of all particles in
the world at any time t zero,
then that Intelligence
could deduce--
had to be pretty
intelligent, by the way--
could deduce their positions and
momenta at all related times.
That's the property of
Newtonian mechanics.
And therefore in
Newtonian mechanics--
if we suppose the Big
Bang known at the time
of Newtonian mechanics--
it would be true
that that action of mine in
dropping the whatever it is--
the Android something
or other-- on the floor
was determined at the
time of the Big Bang.
I think that's absolutely
ridiculous to suppose that.
But anyway, so let me tell
you what the free will
theorem says now.
I believe-- but it's
irrelevant what I believe,
so I shouldn't
even have told you
what I believe-- that
human experiments have
the property that they
compress-- suppose I have
a little box on this table.
It's got a red button
and a green button,
or button A and button
B. Then I believe
that I can press either button
A or button B by a free will
decision that's independent
of the entire past history
of the universe
before I press them.
That I call one bit of free
will-- one binary digit.
I can make a binary choice
independent of the past history
of the universe.
If that is true and various
things about quantum mechanics
and relativity are true-- or
even approximately true-- then
it follows that a spin one
particle that I'm experimenting
on can emerge along
either channel [? C ?]
or channel D in a manner
independent of the past history
of the universe.
That's to say if I have
a certain property,
this spin one particle has
essentially the same property.
It can make a binary decision.
Well, it doesn't actually
make a binary decision.
It doesn't have to think,
what am I going to do?
and then do it.
It just does it.
It does either C or D
in a manner independent
of the past history
of the universe.
That's a theorem.
That's the free will
theorem that I'm saying.
It depends on some
uncontentious facts
about physics, which it's
probably not a good idea for me
to enumerate right now, because,
I mean, as long as you know
that they're there-- and
physicists in general,
have no problem with those.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: And the
paper can be found online.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: It can, yes.
Actually there's a
strong version of it--
the most recent version of it
is called the strong free will
theorem.
When we numerated-- well,
one particular-- one
of these uncontentious
properties
turned out to be
pretty contentious.
That's the property
that I thought
would be the least contentious.
It says, roughly, that
information cannot be
transmitted faster than
a certain finite speed,
which you know will
be the speed of light.
However, that gave rise
to a lot of discussion
among a certain
group of physicists.
What does it mean, information?
Et cetera.
We thought that that would be
the least troublesome thing,
but apparently not.
However, most physicists-- it's
slightly fringe physicists who
find it problematic.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Now I guess
we could take some questions
if there are any questions.
Or we can--
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Oh, come on.
We can't have frightened
you that much.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
Here's a question.
AUDIENCE: First of all, sir, I'm
sorry about the identification
issue.
It's a shame that
the security guards
didn't realize that you were
the Conway responsible for Life.
[LAUGHTER]
My question actually,
though, is also about Life.
And I know you feel
it didn't have--
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Ah!
I hate Life.
AUDIENCE: But don't
you see-- do you
think that there's a
line from your work
to Wolfram's new science book?
Don't you think he was
probably inspired--
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Listen.
This is a problem for me.
I don't want to say anything
negative about Wolfram.
And so I don't want to say
anything about Wolfram.
[LAUGHTER]
I knew Stephen Wolfram
a long time ago.
I met him at a conference in
[INAUDIBLE] near Marseilles
in France, and walked with
him and Norman Packard
down to the beach.
several times-- a
Mediterranean beach.
And we discussed [INAUDIBLE]
all sorts of things.
It's not a question
of a path from me
to Wolfram or from Wolfram
to me or anything like that.
We had enjoyable
conversations then.
You and I met him
fairly recently.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Mm-hm.
Yeah.
And I spoke to him
quite a for the book.
He has very good archives,
whereas John does not.
So that was a real find for me.
And he was generous in helping
me out with a few things.
But then he would
say, well, you should
ask John for his letters.
And I'm like, they don't exist.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yes.
Wolfram didn't believe
that anybody could
be as unsystematic as I am.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Right.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Sorry.
It hasn't answered your
question, but never mind.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
That's a good answer.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
Question of a similar spirit.
If you could comment on your
thoughts about either Dennett.
Daniel Dennett
has done some work
on describing free will
as an emergent property
of determinism in
cellular automata, which
I think is kind of
relevant to your approach.
Or on Whitehead's
process metaphysics
if you're interested
in the links between--
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: I
haven't heard of the latter.
I'd love to meet Daniel Dennett.
He wrote this interesting book
called, I think, "Elbow Room."
You may be familiar with it.
I think the term--
I think that he
should know about the free will
theorem, to tell you the truth.
It's rather strange.
And I'm finding it hard to
articulate what I'm saying.
Probably many
people in this room
have heard of the property
of quantum mechanics
that it only predicts
probabilities.
It does not predict exactly what
happens in a given experiment.
However, we use--
Simon Kochen and I
in proving our free
will theorem-- use
a part of quantum mechanics.
In some circumstances it
predicts a probability of one
that something or other happens.
That is really an absolute
prediction in a certain sense.
However, what it predicts
is a relationship
between observations,
not a single observation.
If you observe a
spin one particle,
work out what its
squared component of spin
is in three
perpendicular directions,
you always get two
ones and a zero.
And therefore if, for
instance, you just observe
two of those three directions
and see that two ones, then
the third direction you know
is a zero without looking.
Equally, if you see a one and a
zero for two of the directions,
you know that the
third direction
is a one without looking.
So those are certain--
Oh, look, there is-- sorry.
Look.
There is a rather
remarkable model.
Hm.
I don't know.
I feel it's a lost
cause if I try
to give some argument about
the free will theorem to you.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Well,
that's a good [INAUDIBLE].
I know-- I think
Daniel Dennett has
seen the paper because
I certainly spoke
to him a fair bit about it.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
Well, I haven't.
And I'd love to.
It sort of contradicts some of
the things he says in the book.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Right.
Yeah, you two should
definitely have a conversation.
That would be nice.
Another question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
both for coming today.
I was wondering if
you could flick back
to the very first slide.
So there was a
photograph of yourself
quite a long time ago with
some electronic equipment.
And there was a circular display
and a rectangular object-- here
it is-- on the table.
And so we were just wondering
before the talk started,
what is this device that you
have here in front of you?
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: I
can't actually see it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It seems--
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Oh, I'm
looking at an old PDP screen.
Yes.
OK.
That was shortly after Life
came out and became very popular
and so on.
The British "Sunday Times"
newspaper came and interviewed
me and a bunch of other
people at Cambridge
who were involved
in the Life Game.
This was a PDP 7
or PDP 8 machine,
which was the first time
we actually programmed
Life on a computer
to see what happened.
People regard it now as
a sort of computer game.
We actually played it with
[INAUDIBLE] on Go boards.
And this was the first time
that it became a computer game.
And I was just
looking at the screen.
AUDIENCE: What was the
input-output mechanism
to program the initial stage
and that sort of thing?
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: I
don't honestly remember.
You could, in some way,
set any number of cells
to be what you wanted them to
be and then press the button.
And it moved on.
This is a sort of typical
newspaper photograph.
I mean, it's-- what do I mean?
They take photographs
which are sort
of staged where you're
holding something and looking
[INAUDIBLE].
Well, you know what newspaper
photographs are like
[INAUDIBLE].
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Right.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming also.
Getting back to the
free will theorem--
I forget if it's
in the paper itself
or in some of the interviews
you did around it-- you drew
a distinction between the
idea of not being determined
by the past and not
being-- even in principle
predictable-- but a distinction
between that and randomness.
And I was unable to
find any place where
you expanded on that
distinction. [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yes.
I will be happy
to expand on it--
very much so-- Because
this is the one thing
that Simon Kochen and I--
you must not think it's
just my theorem.
Simon Kochen is a colleague
of mine at Princeton.
There's one thing that Simon
and I have discovered that seems
to have been totally new.
And in particular,
Einstein got it wrong.
That's something when you find
some way in which you can beat
Einstein, it's pretty good.
So let me tell you what it is.
In the free will theorem itself,
in the first version of it,
we prove that subject--
well, I stated it
before that if human
experimenters have
free will-- one
bit of free will,
they can make one
binary decision-- then
elementary particles, in
particular spin one particle,
has the same kind of free will.
And that just means
independence of past history.
You can make this decision
independent of past history.
Well, now-- OK.
That implies, by an argument I
call the backgammon argument,
that even-- how can I say it?
Even if the world is
deterministic but based
on random numbers,
then still that
will not simulate the world.
I mean, straight off it says the
world cannot be deterministic.
The physical experiments
cannot be deterministic.
But now people
have always opposed
to determinism randomness.
OK?
But randomness doesn't cut it.
If you suppose-- I mean,
it's easily-- I'm sorry.
I'm finding it's
really rather difficult
to articulate what I'm saying.
But even if you suppose that
the world operates according
to deterministic laws, but
that God is playing dice,
so to speak, and
those dice affect
what particles are doing, that's
not a sufficient explanation.
The universe cannot be operated
or simulated by deterministic
laws plus random numbers
injected into the universe.
AUDIENCE: Is there
proof of that?
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yes, and I
will give you the proof of it.
And you can follow
the proof of it.
Here is the way I believe
backgammon tournaments were
conducted at one time.
What you need to
know about backgammon
is comparatively small.
It is a game played with dice.
And whether a move is legal
or not depends on what
the dice [INAUDIBLE].
And backgammon
tournaments used to be
conducted in the
following way, I believe.
Well, you have, say, 50 tables
at which people-- at each table
two opponents are sitting
ready to move things.
And the tournament director
says, the first throw is,
let us say a three and a five.
And at 50 tables the person who
is first to move at that table
makes a move-- legal--
for a three and a five.
And then the tournament
director says, the second throw
is double six.
And then at the 50
tables the other player
makes a move-- legal--
for double six.
So I hope you understand
the situation.
Now suppose instead
of doing that,
instead of throwing
the dice-- sorry,
perhaps I should
say my model so far
has been the tournament
director throws the dice
and says the first throw is a
five and a three or whatever.
But instead of doing that,
does it make any difference--
I'm going to say it obviously
doesn't-- if the tournament
director sits up in his
hotel room the night before
and throws the dice and records
a five and a three then throws
them again and records double
six and so on, and then just
reads them out on the next
day when the tournament takes
place?
That doesn't make
any difference.
I hope people will see that that
doesn't make any difference.
OK.
So suppose God sat
up in his hotel room
the night before the universe
was constructed-- or started--
and threw the dice.
All dice throwing can be
treated as past history.
OK?
So do you understand?
I mean, so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] a
deterministic universe
with random [? oracles ?]
is really still
just a deterministic universe
because the [? oracles ?] might
as well have been preloaded.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yes.
I mean, the random
numbers can be
thrown before the
universe starts--
or really independently
of time, I mean.
And so the proof of the
original free will theorem,
which says that
the universe can't
be simulated by
deterministic laws in terms--
and depending only
on past history now
says it can't be simulated
by deterministic laws
depending on past history and
random numbers-- God's dice.
AUDIENCE: Because
those are effectively
part of past history.
They might [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yeah.
You can treat them as
part of past history
with-- I hope you see it.
Nobody else seems to have
made that rather trivial
observation.
And you see, so here's this
famous saying of Einstein,
I cannot believe that God
plays dice with the universe.
Well, it doesn't matter if God
It makes no difference.
So, yes, the opposite of
deterministic is not random.
It's free.
And I don't quite
know what free is,
but it's not the same
as random because I know
something about what random is.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Next question.
AUDIENCE: I'm sure you were
asked a lot of questions
throughout the whole
biography process.
So I was wondering which
questions you thought
were the most effective in
understanding the way that you
think about the world
and if you could
give a brief answer to maybe
one of those questions.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
That's to me, is it?
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Yes.
Which of my questions were
most effective in eliciting
a description of how you
think about the world?
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
I don't know.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: I tend
to circle around and ask
a lot of questions
again and again,
trying to follow my curiosity
and dig around here and there.
It's a very messy process.
So I don't know if
I would've put--
I think, for me, what
really illuminated
it was letting John
talk and trying
to capture that
to whatever degree
I thought would be
understandable to a fairly
broad audience.
And you are famous for
being able to explain things
to any audience really and
grabbing somebody on the street
and buttonholing
them and telling them
about the free will theorem
because you want everybody
to know and understand it.
So I think it was less
questions-- or not so much
questions as trying
to paint the picture.
Show, don't tell.
So show the man in action.
And so I think you really
do get a sense of how
John is in the world in the
book because I'm portraying it.
I'm not trying to
explain it myself.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yeah.
While you've been
talking, I've been
trying to answer the
lady's question myself.
And I can't do it.
I really don't know which
has been most effective.
I suppose the reader of
the book is the person
to answer that question.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Hm.
I think most people find that
you speaking in your own font
does work, which
was a bit of a risk.
And my editor was calling
it experimental for a while.
She was quite scared
of the whole thing
because it's unconventional.
You're supposed to put
quotes in quotation marks
and the narrator is supposed
to maintain total control.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: A
number of my-- sorry.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: No, no.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: A
number of my friends
who have read the book say,
oh, she's caught you exactly.
So I mean, that's--
well, of course,
she caught me by just standing
her damn tape recorder
on the arm of the-- we sat
together in two adjacent chairs
whose arms had a little flat
surface and she put her damn
tape recorder in between
and switched it on.
And so she actually got
my words, all right.
Of course that meant,
I suppose, that she
was probing and prodding
in the right places
to get these words to come out.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: But you like
to talk, and I'm a listener.
So it was the perfect
match made in heaven.
John talks and talks and talks.
And you're interesting,
so I was happy to listen
for hours and hours.
I have hundreds of
hours of interviews.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yes.
How many hours, do you
think, all together?
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
Easily several hundred.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Really?
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
Yeah, I would think.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
I was guessing 300.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
Yeah, I don't know.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
Yeah, it seems so long.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Scary.
I know far too
much about you now.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yeah,
you do know certain things.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Next question.
AUDIENCE: So when
I was growing up,
my parents had this
rather colorful book--
in both meanings of word-- red
cover with a white illustration
[INAUDIBLE].
And I read that when
I was growing up.
I was around 11, didn't
understand most of it,
but it felt very
interesting in general.
And when I read it
again a few years later
when I was an
undergraduate and I
knew what mathematical
rigor was,
and I discovered
all sorts of things
that were even more interesting
that I didn't learn before.
And when I read it
again a few years later
when I was a graduate student--
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
And what book is this?
Sorry.
Say it again.
AUDIENCE: So this
is "Winning Ways."
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
"Winning Ways."
AUDIENCE: Yes.
And at every level
that I've read it,
I've read it a few times.
And every time it's
interesting and every time I
find out a bit more.
And the question
is basically, is
this sort of thing intentional?
Was it designed to be
accessible at all levels?
Or did it just sort
of fall out that way?
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: This is
a book about children's games
really.
And so let me proceed
for a little bit
without attempting to answer
your question because I
have to describe what
the book is like.
This is a book that Elwyn
Berlekamp, Richard Guy,
and I wrote about how to
play children's games.
Incidentally, I would love to
play Dots and Boxes with any
of you later on to show you how
good the book is, so to speak.
It does really give us
information about how
to play children's games.
Why children's games?
Well, because if you
take grown-up games,
like chess and Go
and so on, there's
really no hope of
getting a theory out,
whereas with
children's games you
can quite often get a rigorous
theory that tells you how
to win and if you're winning.
And it's surprisingly
subtle, as I think
this gentleman made clear.
I don't know how it--
whether this effect you're
saying of-- I mean, I'm
pleased to hear your comments.
Actually, in a way, I'm
displeased as well because--
[LAUGHTER]
--we tried to write
it so that you could
understand it straight away.
And if indeed it's true that
you have to come back to it
and come back to it, it's
not exactly a compliment.
AUDIENCE: When I
was 12, I didn't
know what a class was or
[INAUDIBLE] theory was.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yeah.
No, I'm not complaining really.
I mean, things are
as they are anyway,
not as we'd like them to be.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: But in
a way that sort of nicely
captures you in that you are--
you're very sophisticated,
but you're also very
childish all rolled into one.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
I'm childish?
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Childish,
juvenile, but yet,
a very refined intellectual.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yes.
Actually I remember
telling Siobhan not
to romanticize complexity.
The great discoveries,
at least in my subject,
are not made by doing
complicated things.
They are the
discoveries that tell
you very, very simple things
that people haven't really
noticed.
Actually the case I just
mentioned before of randomness
not cutting it, so to speak,
in the free will theorem
is an instance of this.
Look, that's a very, very
simple observation, OK?
Einstein didn't make it.
Isn't that fantastic?
I feel so proud that we
made this observation which
I can explain to this
audience quite easily.
Einstein didn't get it.
It's absolutely fantastic.
Einstein made lots of
simple observations.
Einstein's observations were
not-- he wasn't terribly good
at mathematics, as he says
himself in certain places.
He didn't know certain
abstract theories.
But he thought in a
very, very simple way.
This is just one of
the simple things
that Einstein didn't notice.
Actually it may be the only one.
I don't know.
So, I mean, it's hard to
make new simple discoveries.
It really is.
When you make them, of course,
everybody understands them.
I hope.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: So maybe we'll
take a couple more questions.
And then--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
My question is more
on building on that
thought that there are some
discoveries that you keep
figuring out as you
go through your day
while playing some
game, say tic-tac-toe.
And the first time I'd
realized when I was a kid,
oh, this can be
won all the time.
That's the basic that
a child first learns.
And then some games you can
count plus 11 each time, plus 1
to 10.
Then you realize if
you start with one,
that you'll always win.
And there are certain
games, but they actually
[INAUDIBLE] game [INAUDIBLE].
But they don't really
cut into applications
that you also mentioned
that hopefully you're
seeing hopefully
before-- in your lifetime
you would like to see some
application of the theory.
So what are the
theories you think
will actually be most
profound in a decade or two?
And then you'll be
really proud of those.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY:
It's hard to say.
I mean, I'd like to
get back, in a way,
to the surreal numbers, because
the surreal numbers were
an application of playing games.
At one time the
British Go champion
was a member of the Cambridge
University mathematics
department.
Many of you will
know the game of Go.
Many of you will not probably.
But I tried to
understand-- he brought
in various friends of his
and they played Go games.
And in Cambridge
people would stand
around kibitzing or
asking each other what
this move-- why this move
was better than that move
and so on.
I tried to understand these
comments and never did.
Let me say I never understood
much about Go anyway.
But I did notice that
near the end of the game,
Go broke up into a
sum of smaller games.
And I had been
meaning to analyze
the notion of sum of smaller
games for quite some time.
And that prompted me
to actually do it.
And then I discovered,
in particular,
that some games
behaved like numbers.
I now say [? were ?] numbers.
And notice that you've
got a simpler development
of the theory of real numbers
by just regarding them as games.
There's an application
of childish game
theory to numbers.
But it didn't stop
at the real numbers.
It went on to the
surreal numbers.
And that's a lovely thing
for me because I like-- well,
in England we say taking the
[? mickey ?] out of people.
I mean, it means-- I suppose
it means taking the microphone,
but I'm not sure.
It means making fun of
people who are particularly
pompous or something.
And here is this serious
theory of the foundations
of the real numbers
and everything
which was developed in the 19th
century by people with beards.
And it came out-- I mean,
this is a simpler theory
than that that came
out of studying
childish games in a way
that people hadn't thought
was worthwhile before.
So there's an application.
It's not quite what
you're talking about.
In fact, it's an application--
you were talking about sort
of [INAUDIBLE] [? implies ?]
[? C, ?] B applied to C.
This is A applied to
B. But it's amazing.
I find mathematics-- I've
always found mathematics
really astonishing
because I don't
know where it all comes from.
I don't know what the ontology
of mathematical ideas is.
Where is two or three or omega?
Wherever they are, it's a place
that has a certain stability.
I like to compare
numbers to cats.
Well, you see, there's
no doubt that cats exist.
And part of the reason
I'm sure about that
is that when you push
a cat, it pushes back.
It doesn't want to go in
the direction you push it.
It wants to do its own thing.
The same is true of numbers.
I mean, you can't make
numbers do what they don't
want to do in a certain sense.
Of course, numbers are different
to cats in some other senses.
I realize that.
[LAUGHTER]
When you're a
little toddler, you
scream to your
mother about things.
I don't know.
And your mother responds.
Your father might
respond too, but anyway.
You don't scream at the wall.
The wall interferes with
your natural progression.
You just can't walk through
walls, but you don't try.
And you don't scream at the wall
in order [INAUDIBLE] let you.
What I'm trying to
say is obstinacy
of things is some kind of
mark of real existence.
OK.
Well, I don't know.
I've been worried
about the sense
in which mathematical notions
exist for a very long time--
ever since I was about 10
probably-- but with gradually
increasing knowledge
and [? abilities ?]
and so on of the way in
which things [INAUDIBLE].
How do they exist?
I mean, they seem to.
And the existence--
People are very confused.
They think that things
like two are concepts.
They aren't.
A concept means something
we conceive in our heads.
Well, two was there a long time
before there were any people
to conceive things.
The statement that Mars has
two satellites-- they're
called Phobos and
Deimos now-- was true
long before there were
any humans to conceive.
So abstract things are
not the same as concepts.
A unicorn isn't the same as
the concept of a unicorn.
The concept of a unicorn exists.
Unicorns don't.
The concept of a horse exists.
Horses do too.
Well, I don't understand it.
I've been thinking about
it for a long, long time
and at different
degrees of depth.
You see, when things
get a little bit more
abstract or a little bit
more infinite or something,
the problems are still the same.
Omega, this infinite number
I spoke of, it exists.
It's not so easy to see
how its existence differs
from the existence of two, but--
My.
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
I'm just going to lapse
into incomprehensibility.
I'd better just stop.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS:
Well, maybe that's
a good place to conclude.
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: Yeah.
OK.
Now listen--
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: We can break--
JOHN HORTON CONWAY: --come and
play Dots and Boxes with me.
SIOBHAN ROBERTS: Or
we could-- I think
you're probably willing to
also take a few more questions.
We could maybe give people a
chance to disperse if you want.
But if you have
more questions, I
think we'd be happy
to receive them.
Thank you all very
much for coming.
And thank you for having us.
[APPLAUSE]